hi everyone and welcome to seee chat
today we're graciously hosted by the
cloud on-air folks they run a webinar
every Tuesday make sure you dial in
weekly they do a lot of exciting topics
my name is Nick Korolev and I am a
customer engineer with Google cloud and
with me is Chris town but Chris you want
to introduce yourself real quick yeah
sure thing hello everyone Chris I'm the
product marketing manager for the
storage and data transfer portfolio at
Google cloud and today we're going to
talk about how to get your data into
Google cloud there's a bunch of
different options for migrating data
some of which might be relevant to a
particular workload or a particular
situation that you have in your data
center or with another cloud provider
but the topic begs the question why do
you want to get your data into Google
cloud platform in the first place what
can you do with it
yeah actually that's very relevant so
exactly to your point to step back and
talk about why you should or how to to
basically optimize moving your data it's
best to talk about why move your data in
the first place so until recently most
customers were interested in moving
workloads to cloud because of the
infrastructure optimization so you have
an application that's running in place a
whether that's on Prem maybe a
colocation or something and you want to
move it to the cloud so you can utilize
benefits of cost efficiency maybe you
need to scale your workload something
like that you want to store some some
backups in the cloud maybe some bursting
but recently we've definitely seen a lot
of customers be interested in the more
digital transformation piece of moving
your workload to the cloud and I know
digital transformation kind of sounds
like a little buzzword but actually it's
it's really true so we're seeing lots of
conversations with with customers in
executive level conversations board
level conversations about how can we
leverage some of the native benefits of
cloud that we're not really utilizing
today so whether those benefits being
moving all your data so you can actually
analyze your data so if you have
terabytes or potentially petabytes of
data it might not be quite so cost
efficient to do that on Prem maybe it's
using Google's machine learning
capabilities we have some really
impressive
natural api's or capabilities with
tensorflow
and leveraging that in our cloud is much
more beneficial because we are we've
already done the legwork for you other
things may be hosting your application
integration with partners scaling out
for employees making things a lot easier
for them there's lots of different
reasons but today we're here to talk
about efficiently migrating your data so
that implies that there's somewhat of a
challenge so Chris what kind of
challenges are there with moving your
data there's a lot of challenges to
moving your data largely due and to the
world we live in when it comes to data
creation so companies individuals
government's organizations everyone is
creating data at an incredible rate
pick your favorite analyst we see data
growth percentages and like 50%
year-over-year we talk to plenty of
customers are actually doubling their
data year-over-year and when you're
dealing with that much data it becomes
challenging to move it cuz there's all
sorts of complexities involved in moving
data from point A to point B a lot of
times you run into network challenges
right so not it's actually can be very
expensive to upgrade your network you
may not have dedicated bandwidth to just
you know dedicated all to moving a large
amount of data and it takes really
specialized resources to start to build
new network infrastructure so a lot of
customers are struggling with that
they're also struggling with you know
just something that's in the nature of
moving data in that it it comes with a
lot of specific challenges because you
want to ensure that the data that you're
moving when it ends up in its
destination is exactly the same as where
it was in its source right so there's a
whole process through checksumming
running into firewall it's like ensuring
that that is complete and it's the the
data integrity as it moves along the way
can be very very complicated and then
just generally everyone is strapped for
time and resources and moving large
amounts of data it can take a lot of
time and a lot of resources okay make
sense yeah
and even when you're incredibly
successful like Evernote was in
migrating there there
essentially their entire infrastructure
over to Google cloud platform you can
see it's a really challenging process so
Evernote actually wrote this incredible
five-part blog series about their
migration effort so I encourage everyone
to go and check it out and they describe
exactly what goes into doing a migration
of this size which was over three
petabytes of data and five billion notes
and attachments within Evernote
including inode somewhere yeah
absolutely
and they dedicated a team of eight
engineers and a serious amount of time
to managing this migration effort now we
know that you as customers and prospects
want to get your data to the cloud and
not everyone has the resources available
like an Evernote or it can dedicate all
their time to this huge migration so we
want to offer solutions regardless where
you are on that journey to get your data
to the cloud efficiently so let's talk
about some of those solutions that are
available from Google cloud and we'll
talk first about why the challenge is so
difficult for moving such a large amount
of data like three petabytes that
Evernote yeah I want to ask so three
petabytes in seventy days sounds really
impressive but how do I kind of
perceptual eyes that in terms of like
what that equates to so can you lay out
just kind of associating what three
petabytes is like and network speeds and
stuff like that yeah definitely um first
we can talk about the one challenge that
we all face in moving data and no matter
how hard we try even as Google like
we're not gonna break the speed of light
barrier which is essentially a
determining factor when you're moving up
from point A to point B maximum so
regardless where you are on the spectrum
of data sizes you can see on the left
hand side of this slide you're gonna
come up to essentially a you know an
opposing network bandwidth in order to
move that that size so there's sort of
this dichotomy between amount of data
and network availability and you find
yourself somewhere on this graph for a
particular data set so in the customers
that I've talked to and I'm sure you've
talked to too we see that a typical
enterprise has you know data sets or
data corpuses of
you know single-digit petabytes let's
call like an average right and you can
see as you go along the spectrum for the
available network you know we oftentimes
see people in 100 megabits or maybe a
gigabit per second
they're lying right so drag your eye
down to the middle of that graph you
could be facing somewhere in a
neighborhood of one hundred twenty four
days to three years to move your data
it's a Google cloud platform I bet that
your business doesn't want to run in
that kind of time yeah my CEO is telling
me that we need to transform our
business I can't tell them well we need
to wait three months four months a year
to do it so yeah that makes sense so
regardless of where you are on the
spectrum both network availability and
the amount of data that you want to move
Google cloud wants to provide solutions
for you to get your data to the cloud
quickly and efficiently cool so let's
talk about a few of these options that
are available from Google cloud platform
and there's basically four core
solutions that we have for migrating
data into Google cloud platform and
we're really talking about just the act
of migrating data so not okay you know
professional services engagement where
you would migrate VMs and all the things
that are like associated with that this
is physically moving like bits from one
place to another so the first one which
almost all of our customers use in some
form or fashion is gsutil which is a
command line interface for moving data
typically from on-premises into Google
Cloud storage okay the second option
that we have is a transfer service and I
I like to refer to this as our cloud to
cloud transfer service basically if you
have data today that is in cloud storage
whether from another cloud vendor like
Microsoft or Amazon or you have it
somewhere in Google Cloud storage a
particular region that you might want to
move it from this is a great solution
for that the third option which I'm
actually gonna spend some more time
later in this presentation going through
because we just reached a major
milestone with this product in reaching
general availability is transfer
appliance which is a relatively new
product from Google cloud that
physically moves data it's really good
for when you have situations where you
have a lot of data and not great network
availability your and then
finally we have a solution that helps
automate the transfer of data from
marketing tools into bigquery for
analysis because a lot of companies are
focusing on the data that they capture
about their customers and prospects and
they want to analyze that data makes
sense yeah
and for these latter three options we
also have many partners in our network
that can help in these sort of
situations - that's good - yeah so let's
talk really quickly about cloud storage
transfer service so basically very
simply this product or service it moves
data from a source to what we call a
data sink now you can call it a sink
bathtub a pool whatever you want to call
it what it's going to end up being in is
a Google Cloud Storage bucket so you are
moving data from a cloud storage source
to a Google Cloud Storage bucket it's
really good to use this product when you
want to synchronize your data from
source to your Google Cloud storage
bucket you expect things to change you
want to make sure the source and the
destination match
it also automates the deletion of source
data once you move it or vice versa you
can for lack of a better word it
essentially has checksumming between the
source and the destination of your data
and for those customers who are already
using Google Cloud storage and say you
want to move from one region to another
region or you want to tear a large
amount of data from hot storage to cold
storage it's also good for that cut of
use case and bigquery data transfer
service like I mentioned is the tool for
marketers right so lots of marketers are
using bigquery to analyze what their
customers are doing and this tool is
fully managed a data import service for
Google bigquery so you see some of the
very popular ads products on the
left-hand side of the screen YouTube
AdWords double-click bigquery can
automate the transfer of data from those
products directly into bigquery awesome
yeah that's really cool and what's nice
is that bigquery is used for all sorts
of different data sets data types for
analyzing data whether it's ad hoc batch
analysis streaming etc but it's not just
for like the the data that you use
through your marking data or
what-have-you so we have customers who
import their data with SAS sources for
instance if you have marketing data you
have CRM data may be event-driven data
or maybe you have databases so sequel
data whether it's my sequel or Postgres
sequel server or even Oracle finding in
some way of basically moving that data
so that you can perform lots of analysis
on multiple data sets combining things
together to get one rational picture and
even your existing data warehouses so if
you have Tara data and Nativa etc it's
really a great source of basically
housing your data like and I'm like how
you called it you sink your pool etc
that's it's definitely applicable
because we meet customers wherever they
are and the benefit of bigquery is that
we scale to meet their demands so
whether you have just a couple gigs a
couple terabytes couple petabytes dozens
of petabytes we can definitely meet you
where you're at with with bigquery and
we have partners as you can see on the
screen who who are able to help migrate
that data so whether you're you are
working with a SAS application or
storage application in terms of
databases we have a bunch of partners
who are able to help migrate that data
efficiently and move it into bigquery
for further analysis that's great oh so
I guess let me ask the question of so
let's say that I have a slow Network and
I want to migrate a whole lot of data
over what are my options well we have a
product pretty good so transfer
appliance I said I want to take a little
bit more time talk about transfer
appliance because it's a brand-new
product to the portfolio essentially
it's our rackable high capacity storage
server for shipping large amounts of
data to Google Cloud rather than sending
it over the network so you can see on
the screen right here is the hundred
terabyte of rob capacity version which
with compression you can achieve you
know potentially double that amount of
data on the device and send us 200
terabytes we also have a for you version
480 terabytes of raw capacity and this
device could move up to a petabyte of
data to the cloud and what's amazing is
it does it much faster than a typical
Network would do it so as we watch this
screen build out we can see transfer
plans could move a petabyte of data
potentially if you're really fast with
the shipping and making sure you give it
back to us in time in 43 days compare
that to what you could do over a typical
network that's like 96% faster to move
your data so back to your comment about
CEOs want to move at the speed of you
know digital transformation this is a
product that could help you do that then
get your data to the cloud faster that's
cool it's also a really simple process
similar to you know ecommerce and online
shopping so all you have to do is go
into the Google Cloud console you
request a transfer appliance will
actually reach out and work with you to
size the right appliance for your
workload a lot of folks would might have
small amounts of data and perhaps
transfer appliance isn't necessarily the
best solution we could probably do it
with GSU tool or some networking
solutions
perhaps they fall somewhere in between
that hundred terabytes of foreign aid
terabytes and they don't know you know
should I order four of one one of the
other so we'll help you out with that
with those considerations once you
request the appliance we ship it via
regular shipping carriers like FedEx and
UPS you receive the appliance you
actually if you want to can wrap it in
your data center which is one of the one
of the reasons why we built transfer
appliance the way that we did because we
know one lots of folks have existing
data centers and to those data centers
don't come with space for various
devices to be littered around the floor
true and three if you're moving a
petabyte of data it's gonna have to live
there
for a little while as it captures all
the data that you want to move so you
can actually rack transfer appliance and
your data
Center connected to the network fill it
up with up to a petabyte of data if you
buy the big one and then you ship the
appliance back to Google where we staged
that in a google cloud storage bucket
where the data then gets decrypted it's
encrypted the entire time oh that's good
oh so your data is secure as you
transfer it and then all you do is you
log back into Google Cloud storage you
supply the decryption keys decrypt that
data and we'll have it available in a
Google Cloud storage bucket and then can
make that data available to all of the
services that you may want to use from
Google cloud platform nice and these are
the decryption keys that I as a customer
set myself that's how Google doesn't
know like what data I'm sending or has
any access to any of that stuff yeah and
it's a really that's a really good point
because as the data transfers via FedEx
across the country wherever you may be
sending it we want that data to be
protected so it's gonna be encrypted the
entire time cool and once the data
transfer is complete the appliance is
erased per miss standards which okay
feel confident with nice yeah
so I mentioned this product recently hit
a milestone of becoming generally
available and this happened about two
weeks ago at the end of June and a few
new features were included in a general
availability that I think would be super
interesting to the audience one is you
can now mount your transfer points and
receive it as network-attached storage
so we know probably anywhere from a
third to a half of the workloads in a
typical enterprise are referencing some
sort of file storage so this might make
it really easy for you to drag and drop
your files or rsync
those files from where they are today in
so transfer appliance we release an
income in console request process so you
can see and request transfer appliance
in the same console that you're using
Google Cloud Storage and all the other
services and then an end-to-end
integrity check so this goes back to one
of those challenges that I mentioned at
the beginning of the presentation you
want to ensure that the bits and the
source and the bits in the destination
are exactly the same yeah because you
want any application that's referencing
them
any analyst who wants to analyze that
data to ensure they're looking at the
same data so we have an N end integrity
check to make sure that you're confident
doing so here so tracer appliances been
in beta for about a year and through
that process we were able to learn from
the many customers who use it some
really cool use cases that transfer
appliance is particularly successful
with so I thought I'd bring that up to
get the ideas flowing about ways that
folks may use transfer appliance today
so one of the really interesting ones is
to use it to seed a proof of concept for
another Google cloud product so you
mentioned machine learning and AI
initiatives lots of customers want to do
that oh yeah we have lots of api's like
ml vision or the the image recognition
API so I'm so if you want to test those
on say like a large corpus of images
that you have on-premises today say 100
terabyte library of images like a good
way to send that to us and check out
some of our machine learning solutions
would be to use transfer appliance to
transfer that data okay make sense um
one that we didn't necessarily expect
but bubbled up as a really cool use
cases to collect data from other vendors
or research organizations and bring that
to Google cloud for analysis so you can
actually send transfer appliance like
out to Geographic or weather data
vendors
collect data there and bring it in I'll
talk about a couple customers in a
second that are using it in that manner
lots of folks have a transfer process
today that's usually disparate and very
manual you're collecting tapes you're
restoring those tapes you may be pulling
data from an ad source on Prem and then
you're kind of getting all that data
together and then sending it over
transfer plans can help with that of
course data center migrations as you
move to the cloud and through the data
center migration what we find customers
doing is they're taking the opportunity
to kind of clean their storage house
like delete the data that's no longer
needed and only move there are the good
stuff which is your transfer appliance
can be a catalyst yeah definitely yeah
and then finally
what is probably most often used for and
the best use case is really dense rich
large amounts of content so media
archives images regulatory content that
you need to keep for seven years because
you're you know SEC regulated for
instance right you can move that data to
the cloud these transfer plants okay
yeah so I mentioned I talked about a few
interesting customers this first one a
shipment ocean Institute it's a
nonprofit research organization it's
really interesting they're actually the
only research vessel with a high
performance computing center on board
Wow while they're sailing in it while
they are sailing and what that offers
their researchers is access to
technology like in the moment when
they're gathering data yeah and also the
ability to capture more and different
types of data that they never had before
so what they do is they actually mount
transfer appliance onboard the RV Falkor
as it goes on its expedition they
collect all the data to transfer
appliance and then they when they come
back to port that data gets sent to
Google Cloud storage and then that's how
they distribute the data that they
collected to all the researchers huh
okay Airbus and it's in particular its
Airbus defence and space geo arm of
Airbus they use transfer appliance to
really lift and improve their storage
architectures so they have access to
some really exclusive radar and
different types of satellites I mean
they're capturing these earth
observation images and they're they're
providing access to that library of
images to the world you can see the
image on the screen is actually a black
rock city from Birmingham I noticed so
they're capturing all these amazing
images obviously that accounts for a lot
of data that they were collecting
on-premises so they use transfer
appliance to move that data to the cloud
Beatport has a really interesting use
case and they want to be able to serve
their library of music content as fast
as possible to listeners so they use
transfer appliance to move the entire
digital library that they have in a
Google Cloud storage because they knew
that Google Cloud Storage performance
in in particular with content serving is
the best out there and then finally I
mentioned that that interesting use case
of collecting research from vendors so
this is actually a Google X company
called Makani and what they do you can
see in the image is they fly wind kites
really high up in the air because turns
out the wind blows harder if you go up a
few hundred meters right so they can
generate energy faster with turbines
that are 100 meters into the air and
they could in something that's you know
just a typical wind mill yes wow that's
got to be an interesting challenge to
kind of deal with yeah um but it's
really important that they pick the
right spots right because you need to
pick an area that weather wise and wind
wise is appropriate so they use transfer
appliance to collect data from research
vendors bring it in a Google cloud and
then analyze and run some models on that
to pick where they're gonna tether their
wind kites now regardless of what your
use case is what kind of data you're
moving it's going to end up in Google
Cloud storage so let's take a second to
introduce or remind folks of what Google
Cloud Storage is it's our object storage
solution it's one product which is very
important because that's differentiated
in the market place that essentially
comes in four flavors based on the
availability or redundancy that you need
for your particular workload okay
so from left to right on this screen you
have multi-regional which means geo
redundant storage regional which means
in one particular region where your data
is stored near line and cold line which
are essentially cold and archival
storage options and the price follows
the availability from left to right
about this screen and Chris I've got a
question for you and just as a reminder
to our audience there's live Q&A at the
bottom so make sure you're typing these
questions and we'll answer some
questions at the end but I frequently
heard this cause this question from
customers of so there's four different
tiers of GCS the multi regional regional
near line and cold line that kind of
implies that as you tear things down
you're getting a degraded performance I
mean how does performance work in terms
of these different four flavors yeah
that's a really good question and it's
really awesome
answer from Google because it doesn't
change so the user experience of
requesting a object in multi-regional or
requesting an object in cold line will
be exactly the same it will come back in
milliseconds of latency because
essentially a single API yeah across
these we just allow you the option to
tear that storage based on costs or
stuff that's not going to get accessed
as frequently yeah okay
cool so I have a obviously a lot of
customers who are using GCS and so it's
it's I think it's valuable to talk about
the different reasons people typically
use use yes and those generally fall
into the three buckets that you see on
the screen so first being content
storage and delivery so GCS is
essentially limitless object storage so
whether you're storing videos like Vimeo
music like Spotify websites multimedia
maybe your mobile web applications it is
a fantastic place for storing your
content for the delivery through whether
it be through CDNs or like you said
through the incredible latency that ACS
naturally provides the second big
category is around data analytics and
general compute so if anyone's familiar
with Hadoop for instance or GCE you can
leverage data proc to store all of your
back-end analytics data that you're
gonna crawl through create Hadoop
clusters destroy Hadoop clusters etc and
it really helps in terms of being able
to scale storage and compute
independently and so we have a bunch of
customers for instance the Broad
Institute who uses GCS for doing some
genomics data because obviously those
genomics data sets are massive yeah
or Philips as another example of being
able to collect all the IT sensor data
from everyone really across the globe
and being able to surface it up through
the Philips a pet cetera being able to
drive a lot more insights and
capabilities to their customers than
what would have normally been possible
yeah and then the final category being
kind of at the general back up archival
and storage repository for your data so
if you are interested in for instance
like a hybrid cloud approach or multi
cloud
approach being able to store your data
in multiple places whether that be
through a backup through an archive and
what's nice is that we work with a whole
bunch of different partners for instance
Dell AMC NetApp beam Veritas etc where
you can essentially leverage your
existing solution on Prem or in the
cloud and then configure as a backup
repository GCS so that you can store
your backup data in GCS more efficiently
yeah most of those most common backup
providers you can just choose GCS as a
drop-down exactly yeah yeah I've done it
before
yep yeah so I wanted to I wanted to kind
of double click on one point I mentioned
one product for GCS which is really
important in the storage world because
when it comes to storage we want a lot
of rich features right we want to have
some of your data being geo redundant in
case of a disaster
you probably want some of your data to
be pushed to the edge close to your
users as possible so that the experience
is really really fast you want to have
some of your data in cold storage so
that you don't have to pay as much
because it's not getting used for the
next three years right so with Google
Cloud Storage you get all those features
in one single product in a single API
where if you went out in the marketplace
typically you're gonna have to purchase
multiple products in order to achieve
the same amount of functionality so I
kind of want to prove that really quick
in a demo so we're gonna talk in
particular about edge caching so
obviously lots of customers serve
content to users right and they serve
content to those users throughout the
globe so what I'm going to essentially
mimic is a user requesting content from
far away and let's see how fast Google
Cloud Storage ok get it to them put it
to the test
yeah so we're gonna make this as hard as
possible we're gonna choose the region
that's farthest away from us today okay
so anyone can go to this site it's
called juicy pink comm and it basically
will tell me how far away these regions
are so right now it thinks that I'm
farthest away from Frankfurt and Belgium
Sydney
and great so we can choose the belgium
region okay oh wow to continue my google
cloud show so first I will create a
bucket actually for the sake of time I'm
looking at the screen I'm gonna use one
of the buckets I've already created so
if we go back to this see the one that's
pretty far that I already have a bucket
for so Mumbai is actually really really
far away yes so three hundred five
milliseconds so I have a Mumbai bucket
thankfully okay and we'll take a look at
the data that's in this Mumbai bucket so
for those who aren't familiar object
storage works essentially you have
buckets and you put data into that and
you put objects into that so I have a
bucket in Mumbai region I have a few
images here available to me a photo I
was doing a demo in Tel Aviv not too
long ago so I had a picture at Tel Aviv
a Google wind farm photo and I actually
had this photo of this this Lego
figurine in a chicken suit okay house he
would as you would so I'm gonna ask once
I reconnect this show I'm essentially
gonna ask the system how long it takes
for me standing here to request that
image the Lego chicken image from Mumbai
yeah cuz he's currently serving a
round-trip okay so I have the script
already run this time pearl it's gonna
essentially give me that information and
we will wait a second and then here you
can see it takes one point six seconds
okay right which it's actually super
fast when I think about Jabbar that it
is traveling but with Google Cloud
storage we can do this much much faster
because we have edge caching actually
built into our solution so once I share
this image publicly I'll run the curl
again I'll do it one more time down 20
milliseconds shoes because six 2.02 it's
incredible at is like 99 something
percent probably yeah
so because of GCS recognize that I'm the
user who's requesting this information
and it wants to push that image as far
as close to me as possible so golly in a
edge location somewhere here in Mountain
View okay yeah that's cool so let's get
back over to the slides and let's talk
about the first option that we
introduced gsutil and some of the
performance tricks associated with that
yeah definitely
so I frequently hear this comment from
customers of I have a lot of data to
transfer I've decided on GSU tool are
there some ways of optimizing geo co2 so
that I can migrate the data easier and
the answer is yes so there's a couple
slides that'll go through kind of tips
and trip tricks on how to do it
first thing to be mindful of is location
location location so just like you
showed if you have all your data stored
in the US and you create a storage
bucket at Mumbai and then you replicate
all your data to Mumbai probably not
going to be the most efficient way of
doing it in fact we have this site cloud
Google com sascha bout slash locations
where we have currently over 16 regions
I think it's 49 zones in 35 different
countries and over a hundred points of
presence so definitely find the region
that's closest to you in fact later this
summer we're opening up a region in Los
Angeles which is pretty awesome so make
sure you stay up to date with the
regions that are available secondly if
you're uploading a lot of small files
you may not know this but every object
storage out there has some sort of
latency or some sort of small overhead
that happens when you actually push a
file to the the ending destination or
the ending bucket so being able to push
let's say 500 small files or of 125
kilobytes in size actually gets
associated with a large amount of
unnecessary overhead so if you consider
GS utils multi-threaded option the juice
util - M option you can actually multi
thread all of these smaller files into
one big push to GCS and as you can see
on the graph on the left we did a test
where we actually saw for two over four
times the amount of throughput just by
using this - Emma
so definitely something to consider if
you have a bunch of small files now
conversely if you have maybe some really
large files so you're doing some video
uploads some multimedia uploads maybe
some really large log files or something
like that there's another option of
actually breaking one large object into
multiple smaller objects and it's called
composite parallel uploads so we have
this another gsutil option where
essentially when you perform an upload
of let's say one massive file so on the
left you can see a 500 megabyte file we
actually split that up into multiple
chunks upload those in parallel and then
once they all arrive in GCS GCS actually
combines them together and then performs
a checksum to make sure that everything
got compiled successfully and as you can
see on the left-hand side we see quite a
bit of a performance improvement by
using this option compared to the
default option yeah now one thing to be
aware of though is that you should not
be using this for near line or cold line
storage the reason why pretty simple is
that when you upload all these small
little chunks and then it combines those
chunks into one big chunk it actually
deletes those individual chunks and with
Nearline and colon storage because these
are longer-term storage mediums it's
meant to say your objects are meant to
say for 30 days 90 days depending on the
storage class so if you're performing a
composite parallel upload you're
actually behind the scenes deleting each
of those individual chunks as they get
combined into one big object and so
you'll get charged essentially for those
individual chunks that have to be
deleted so make sense just something to
be aware of and another thing to keep in
mind is you have to be considered or
considerate of sequential files so if
you're uploading but for instance log
files or sensor data that uses a
traditional or standard kind of naming
convention what happens under the covers
is that you're actually uploading these
sequential files to maybe the same
back-end
excuse-me servers within GCS so you can
actually be throttling yourself by just
your name is standard alone so something
to keep in mind is
maybe use like a hash in front of the
the filenames or maybe rename your file
folders stuff like that as you can see
from the screenshot on the bottom we saw
2x improvement by simply renaming files
so another thing to keep in mind
and then lastly obviously moving your
data is important but what if you have
like an entire application that you want
to move you want to you want to lift and
ship lift and shift application a from
from your data center to to GCP and you
want it to remain exactly like
application a yeah well fortunately we
have a whole bunch of partners that we
work with for instance fellow strata
cloud on door who can do that for you so
if you have a Windows server you have a
Linux server maybe you have a VM
environment you can perform that lift
and shift quite easily yeah also yeah
it's fantastic so with that we're going
to stay tuned for live QA so we'll be
back in less than a minute and we'll
answer your questions
you
hey everyone welcome back so thank you
everyone for writing up a whole bunch of
questions we have some good ones there
so Chris I guess I'll ask you the first
question when should you use gsutil
versus the storage transfer service
great question super simple answer okay
so when you're moving data from
on-premises into the cloud and you don't
have the challenges that we talked about
which would lead you to transfer plants
use gsutil okay because most of our
developers especially use gsutil to move
their data if you want to go from one
cloud storage location whether that be
an another cloud storage provider or us
to a Google Cloud storage new transfer
service okay pretty clear-cut cool well
I guess on to the second question how
can I get the status or other
information on transfers can this
information be visualized so status
updates and further information on the
progress of your transfer that's
something what we're thinking about
integrating into the console in the
future okay we have standard tracking
associated with the appliance through
the shipping vendor mm-hmm okay and that
information not it cannot be visualized
today what is it
okay I guess I'll take the third one
would you recommend the transfer
appliance to migrate on-prem VMware VMs
to Google Cloud so the transfer
appliance is more for data itself rather
than applications so we actually have a
great solution for specifically for
VMware I'm called Belo strata della
Strada was actually a company that
Google acquired I think it was about a
month ago maybe two months ago but it's
really easy to basically migrate your
VMware VMs by essentially installing a
little agents I think on V Center and
then you have some new options in VMware
to essentially create the destination
where you're going to replicate your VM
to you'll in the background synchronize
the data and then we make it very easy
for you to perform that cutover
migration once you have all the
networking the firewalls all the kind of
ancillary ancillary pieces set up make
it really easy for you yeah so and by
the way the Velo strata solution is
totally free for performing migrations
into GCP I mean obviously there's GC
cost ya of like running your VM on GCP
but the actual act of migration through
Bill Estrada is totally free so
definitely check it out yeah cool I
guess I'll take number four again as
well rather than uploading my data onto
the transfer appliance can I just ship
you a copy of my storage array this is
this is interesting because I used to be
in the storage industry so I'm very
familiar with the storage arrays so the
answer is unfortunately no you can't
just ship us your EMC or your net up or
what have you storage array at least you
can't ship us it but we do work with
partners like Iron Mountain where you
can ship your storage array to our
partners and they have incredibly fast
backbone network connection to GCP and
they can suck all the data off your
storage right and then put it right into
GCS yeah and I guess I'll - I'll have
you take the last question what if I
have data that changes frequently can I
still use the transfer appliance yeah
you can use it but probably not in the
way that you were thinking so a great
use case would be to use transfer
appliance to seed
whatever that workload is it's going to
change frequently so let's take backup
as an example you could take all of your
historical backups move them with
transfer appliance and then
incrementally backup over the network
from ok right so this transfer place can
actually accelerate the process of
moving your data even if it's going to
change ok cool
well that's about it for time so thank
you everyone for joining see each at our
next session is data science for social
change that sounds really interesting
I'm gonna be tuning in to that so I hope
everyone sticks around and watches that
until then I guess see you at see chat
next week
thanks everyone thanks
you